Das hier ist kein Gemälde
das ist Style-Transfer. Wir nehmen den Inhalt eines Bildes und kombinieren ihn mit dem Stil eines anderen. Das ganze funktioniert mit Texturen
Und mit Gemälden
Wir benutzen dafür neuronale netze eine form von künstlicher intelligenz
und Styletransfer ist gerade nur eine art und weise wie KI die kunstwelt verändert herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video auf doktor watson
Kunst. Etwas das nur wir menschen erschaffen können. Ein kreativer Prozess der auf wahrnehmung
Vorstellung und Intuition fußt. Kunst soll menschen eine neue Perspektive zeigen, der
Gesellschaft einen Spiegel vorhalten und inspirieren. Eine Maschine die nur Zahlen berechnet kann so etwas doch nicht verstehen, oder?
nun schauen wir doch einfach mal. Style transfer das Beispiel aus dem Intro ist zwar schön, aber
zugegebenermaßen auch nicht mehr als ein Filter. Der Inhalt bleibt derselbe
nur der Stil wird verändert und in den meisten fällen verwendet man als Vorlage für diesen Stil sogar ein Kunstwerk eines menschlichen
Künstlers. Die KI hat hier also keine wirklich kreative Entscheidung getroffen. Anders sieht das schon beim Artbreeder aus. Das Experiment von
Joel Simon funktioniert im browser und kann zwei bilder miteinander
fusionieren. Die Ergebnisse sind manchmal faszinierend und manchmal verstörend, aber in jedem falle eins
neuartig.
Noch besser wird es bei Generatoren wie thispersondoesnotexist. Auf dieser website findet man Gesichter von Menschen die es nicht gibt.
Eine künstliche Intelligenz hat sich die Gesichter ausgedacht und das ziemlich überzeugend. Manchmal mit Brille, manchmal mit Bart.
Übrigens habe ich euch alle KI tools, die man selber ausprobieren kann, unten in der Videobeschreibung verlinkt
darunter auch das hier, den deep dream generator, denn wenn künstliche Intelligenzen anfangen zu träumen dann wird es richtig spannend
diesen deep dream stil kennen wir wahrscheinlich schon ziemlich trippy und weird, aber es ist einer der ersten
originellen KI Stile, den mann als solchen erkennen kann. Deep Dream Art ist ein Begriff.
Was ihr vielleicht noch nicht kennt sind die vielen tausend anderen Stile, die auf ähnliche Weise erzeugt werden, aber oft ganz anders aussehen
Das hier sind die Bilder vom Künstler Mario Klingemann, den ich in München interviewen durfte.
Das faszinierende am Arbeiten mit neuronalen netzen ist, dass sie mehr im Gegensatz zu der
klassischen zum klassischen Ansatz der generativen Kunst, wo ich jetzt ein Programm schreibe,
bestimmte regeln aufstelle und dieses Programm sich innerhalb der regeln in einem Spielraum bewegen kann
bei neuronalen netzen ich im grunde genommen
nicht mehr Programmierer, sondern eher
wie ein Fotograf mich in einem Raum den ich selbst geschaffen habe bewege und dann interessante
Locations, Örtlichkeiten suche und dann mir eben die Ausschnitte wähle,
die ich dann interessant finde oder die ich besonders finde.
Mario Klingemann sieht sich selber also weniger als Künstler, der den Pinsel schwingt, sondern eher als Entdecker
er bewegt sich durch die Welten, die er mit seinen Programmen selber geschaffen hat und sucht nach neuartigen dingen, die er spannend findet
nach dem Gespräch mit Mario habe ich mir viele fragen gestellt. Wenn Mario auf
entdeckungstour geht und sich die besten bilder heraus sucht, heißt das dann, dass er selber gar nicht der Künstler ist, sondern eher der Kurator
wem gehören die Bilder, wenn sie doch durch Zufall entstanden sind. Und überhaupt, was ist eigentlich Kunst?
Weil ich ja generell eine faule Person bin, zitiere ich hier einfach mal wikipedia: "im engeren Sinne werden damit Ergebnisse gezielter
menschlicher Tätigkeit benannt die nicht eindeutig durch Funktionen festgelegt sind."
Aha! Es muss also von einem Menschen gemacht worden sein, damit es Kunst wird. Direkt danach steht aber das hier:
"der Formationsprozess des Kunstbegriffs unterliegt permanent einem Wandel, der sich entlang von dynamischen Diskursen, Praktiken und
institutionellen Instanzen entfaltet. Man könnte argumentieren, dass genau das gerade passiert. Eine neue Praktik die arbeit mit künstlicher intelligenz
verändert den Kunstbegriff.
Im Oktober 2018 wurde zum Beispiel das mit KI erstellte Gemälde "Edmond de Belamy" in new york für stolze
432.000 dollar versteigert. KI ist hier definitiv angekommen.
Man könnte aber auch argumentieren, dass künstliche intelligenz nur das Werkzeug der menschlichen Künstler ist. Sie ist etwas indirekter als ein Pinsel,
würde aber ohne menschliches zutun gar nichts erzeugen
Mario Klingemann muss immer noch den Programmcode schreiben, sich Gedanken machen und stellt seine besten werke aus. Er ist der Künstler.
Und ich finde sogar dass KI Werke genau die Anstöße geben, die Kunst für viele ausmacht, sie inspirieren, geben Menschen eine neue Perspektive
und halten der Gesellschaft einen Spiegel vor. KI verändert gerade die Gesellschaft in so vielen Bereichen,
dass es manchmal schwierig ist bei allem mit zu kommen. Das nur noch etwas vermeintlich inhärent menschliches, wie Kunst, mit Hilfe von KI geschaffen wird
verdeutlicht diesen wandel und zeigt auch, dass keine branche davon verschont wird.
40 Prozent aller Jobs könnten in den nächsten 15 Jahren durch Automatisierung verloren gehen.
Vielleicht sind sogar Künstler davon betroffen. Um das zu testen haben wir in den letzten tagen ein neuronales netz mit 40 doktor watson
Videos gefüttert und das dazu gebracht ein komplett neues Doktor Whatson Video zu schreiben und das hier ist das Ergebnis:
"Ich habe in diesem Video angekündigt, dass ich meine Meinung über Wissenschaft und Technologie ein wenig ändern werde.
Neulich sagte ich meinem Roboter, dass ich nach Frankreich ziehen würde.
Er sagte dass Frankreich das gleiche Problem hatte wie Deutschland. Es gibt keine aktiven Vulkane und es gibt keine Brunnen.
Er hatte Recht! Zumindest an manchen stellen weigern sich Wissenschaftler die Auswirkungen von anthropogenen Faktoren auf die Umwelt zu untersuchen."
Vielleicht bin ich meinen Job doch nicht jetzt sofort, los Gott sei dank.
Aber es gibt schon einige coole Tools, die uns hier in der Kreativbranche echt unter die Arme greifen.
Mit dem "content aware fill" in vfx Programmen, können wir zum beispiel ganze Autos verschwinden lassen. Das funktioniert mit künstlicher intelligenz
und auch, wenn die Funktion nicht immer ein perfektes Ergebnis
liefert, macht sie mit wenigen klicks etwas möglich was vor drei Jahren noch aufwändiger Handarbeit und vor 20 Jahren beinahe unmöglich gewesen wäre.
Mit einem faceswap erzielen manche user im Internet bereits bessere Ergebnisse, als hunderte Profis, die mühsam ein Gesicht rekreiert haben.
Und Netflix hat die ersten zwei staffeln von house of cards bestellt,
weil ein Computerprogramm die Daten der Netflix Zuschauer analysiert hat und die Kombination aus kevin spacey
david fincher und politthriller
besonders erfolgversprechend war. Nicht, weil ein Drehbuchautor eine gute Idee hatte.
Inzwischen müssen wir nicht mal mehr Musik produzieren.
Das was ihr das ganze video über im Hintergrund gehört habt. sind Songs die mit Hilfe von künstlicher Intelligenz erstellt wurden.
Im Musikwettbewerb "beats und bits", vom Wissenschaftsjahr konnten Künstler ihre KI-Songs einreichen und vor kurzem startete das Publikumsvoting.
Unter dem link in der Videobeschreibung könnt ihr euch alle eingereichten Songs anhören und abstimmen, welche ihr am besten findet.
Okay. Heute und auch in den nächsten Jahren wird KI noch keine abend füllenden Kinofilme, oder Computerspiele
mit bewegender Story generieren. Aber was wir heute schon sehen, hören und selber ausprobieren können zeigt uns die Richtung, in die es gehen wird.
Wie ist eigentlich bei allen Bereichen, die durch künstliche Intelligenz verändert werden ist, ist er eine Unterstützung. Ein Werkzeug, das den Menschen helfen soll.
Vielleicht erledigt sie nervige Arbeit, hilft bei der Wahl des Themas, oder sie kreiert sogar neue Bilder. Aber der kreative Prozess
wird immer noch von einem Menschen gesteuert.
Die spannende Frage für die Zukunft ist ,ob KI irgendwann einmal etwas wirklich neuartiges
kreieren kann, das mit Konventionen bricht. Aktuell lernt sie das, was sie gefüttert wurde und kreiert
dementsprechend auch nur Werke in diesem Rahmen. Aber die größten Künstler aller Zeiten waren eben nicht die, die den perfekten
Durchschnitt getroffen haben. Sie haben neue Dinge gewagt, regeln gebrochen und
polarisiert. So etwas zu berechnen wird nicht leicht
Deswegen hier mal eine Frage an euch: Hättet ihr ein Problem damit, wenn eure Unterhaltung komplett von einer KI stammt?
Könnten ihr an einem berechneten Film Spaß haben?
Und sind die Gefühle die uns ein KI Gemälde vermittelt falsch, weil die KI diese Gefühle nie selber gespürt hat?
Schreibt mir eure Meinung dazu gerne unten in die Kommentare, ich bin sehr gespannt was ihr zu diesem Thema zu sagen habt.
Das hier ist das vierte und letzte
Video von mir im Wissenschaftsjahr 2019: Künstliche Intelligenz.
Wenn ihr hier oben klickt, dann kommt ihr zu einer Playlist mit allen KI Videos von mir,
darunter die Frage ob KI gut oder böse ist, wie selbstfahrende Autos funktionieren und wie KI die Medizin verändert.
Vielen dank an die gemeinnützige Organisation "Wissenschaft im Dialog" und an das "Bundesministerium für Bildung und Forschung" für die Unterstützung bei diesem Video.
Vielen dank an euch fürs Zuschauen und wie immer bleibt neugierig.
Euer Cedric